i know that there has been some talk in
regards to a prenup agreement
yeah i have to know that
you know you're not here for just what
he has oh talk about a straightforward
approach
i didn't come here to
play games today shaida and balau's
ex-wife shahida
shaida shahida shaida shahidah
have an intense conversation about
shaida signing a prenup
i feel completely caught off that like
where does this hostility come from
what do y'all think she should do would
you sign it he needs to protect himself
and for the children's sake
oh chada can't catch a break
everything feels different now
i think it's like welcome to america
scheida let's get into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melissa happy
fourth of july to those out there who
wish to celebrate in the u.s
i have to throw that last little bit in
there because you know
it's just a lot going on but
nevertheless
we're not here to talk about that i do
feel a type of way before we get into
this woman to woman convo between shaida
and balau's ex quick update on ari benny
and
leandro
remember during last week's episode ari
have majority of us asking
[Music]
when she revealed she's taking her
ex-husband leandro wedding dress
shopping with her
i don't want he's choosing my wife's
dress i wish he's getting my life that's
what i want
well fast forward to this week the day
has come for them to finally go but it
just so happens that ari isn't feeling
well i'm a little nauseous
i'm gonna ask maybe a two intrusive
question but
when was the last time you
got your period
after leandro steps into doctor mode he
offers to drive benny to the store to
get a pregnancy test
i shouldn't be holding this bank you
should hope yeah yes but
your future
well based off how close you and ari are
it's your future too leandro
anyway all right let me take this stone
darn test when they return to the house
ari takes the test
and it is
[Music]
negative who saw that coming
a part of me thought hmm maybe
but
at this point i know how these 90-day
teases work
bettiam was disappointed by the news but
ari had to remind him
why we don't have any money for another
kid
and speaking of binyum lucky for him he
could have a break from leandro for now
leandro's leaving new jersey to head
back to his home in indiana
all right moving on to shaida and balao
and let me tell you now i am ready
and welcoming your hot takes
i don't know what it is about these two
but anytime i talk about them y'all go
in so i can't wait to hear what you have
to say about this situation
are you tired
a little bit
quick refresh these two are just getting
back from their trip to atlanta where
balau sprung the conversation of a
prenup on chida in the middle of a
romantic day bottom line i feel that we
should not have a prenuptial agreement i
feel as if they don't trust me chida
understandably taken aback by the timing
of this conversation gets advice from
her sisters and they tell her
if he wants her to sign a prenup she
needs to add her own condition before
signing it should i like say okay i want
to have kids before 40.
definitely i definitely if you really
want it if this is something you really
want then definitely put yourself in the
freedom shaida's sisters do what sisters
should do
build you up and give you the courage to
go face whatever it is you have to face
it's just that when she did bring it up
to bilal i was thinking maybe we could i
need to put a time frame on this
contract when it comes to having
children his face said it all
and you could see the confidence she
built up to have that conversation
once you think that you want to make
sure that things are are good and right
in a relationship
specifically between us before you i can
see the exact same for you just trickle
away
all of that brings us to this week's
episode where bilal is in a mood
ever since atlanta you could feel the
tension and the energy is
quite sour
when bilat gets upset
he stays quiet he don't look you in your
face
and then after you you start feeling all
the negative vibes it's just not what i
envision
my march life will be like
well
that's what you're getting girl i get
that some people you have to let them
have their moments it may take them a
little longer to get over things
but in my relationships
it only takes so long before i get
annoyed
when someone holds on to an attitude for
longer than you know
is necessary
to me it just comes off as childish for
one you're not hurting anyone but
yourself and for two you're spending all
that time being mad
we can be coming up with a solution
it's all a choice shyda's not upset and
she's the one getting suspected of being
a gold digger
[Music]
seeing that the kids are here
probably all of us could do something
i mean
there's actually nice blue skies outside
i can't make that go to waste right
what do you think about us doing
something like yoga
yoga
blou get up
and see chada still has a smile on her
face that's love she's accepting her man
for who he is
flaws and all
listen
i know you're not feeling up to it
you're looking very dumb and mellow and
sad
but um i'll show you when we are done
you'll feel so much more better
and that's what i want
i'm feeling
just
not like myself i don't i don't feel
like we're vibing we're on that level i
mean we have some pretty big issues like
prenup and baby talk you know it's just
it's just
they take the kids outside and shydah
gives everyone a course in yoga
are you hearing how peaceful the wind
sounds
so peaceful
i just heard butter fart
don't leave that foot up the loud oh i
was on some advanced stuff benny he's
done everyone bring the knees down
bring your knees together just sit and
hear a pulse and just relax
and shadow was right going outside to
move and get some fresh air
standing ovation
thank you
helped blough get out of his funk well
kind of
when you stress me out
i like to get away and just
be quiet
you know
breathe deep breathing you know so like
that part helped a lot
so
did i get my mind back you seem to be
you've never not had them it's just that
sometimes
you say and do things
and forget i'm just kissing me yeah so
below tells the camera that although
they made up they argue a lot so as of
right now they are not ready to walk
down the aisle all right fast forward to
when ex-wifey came through i was a
little worried when you called asking to
like talk to me
because you know i just i just want
everything to be okay so i was like okay
did i do something
no um i just felt like
we needed to have a conversation
especially with the fact that the lao
and i co-parent and it's a very positive
co-parenting experience yeah what i can
tell you about myself i'm very stern
when it comes to my kids
and so what i want is the best for them
and what i want them to be around is
someone who is the best for them
i know there are going to be some mixed
reactions about her approach i can't
wait to see what y'all say i do feel a
type of way in regards to blou not
setting up a meeting with us early on
when she first came i think that that's
very important because she needs to
understand where i fit at in the
dynamics of everything shahida tells
shaida that she really doesn't know much
about her and shada gives a little bio
from trinidad i grew up in a strict
islamic household okay i know about
family i have a lot of siblings i have a
lot of nieces and nephews after that
bellow's ex doesn't hesitate to bring up
the prenup and it may not be my place to
speak on it shot is like right exactly
i'm coming from a place of protecting my
kids yes assets and
the generational wealth you know that he
has i have to know that
you know you're not here for just what
he has
hmm she did say she was stern
and i could imagine how offensive that
is for chyda to keep getting asked if
she wants blau just for what he has
when she's a quality woman who deserves
a man of below stature and the thing
about shaida is that she doesn't shy
away from the fact that she finds what
bilal has built for himself to be
attractive i mean
who would it
and observe these qualities with him
just by judging his online pictures he
seemed ambitious you know he seemed
striving and also
i was attracted to him you know i was
like okay he takes good care of his body
he looks well put together type of
gentleman yeah at this point i seriously
doubt if her motive is to marry below
then divorce him and take all he has
who does that
well
there are people who do that but she is
clearly into him and this is coming from
someone who when she first got to
america
i thought she was more interested in his
money
but after learning more about their
story and getting a better gist of who
she is
my perspective has changed i have a life
in trinidad i'm very new in my cup in my
community
um i'm gonna hide my own yoga studio
and
just google me you'll see a lot of
things that come up you know i was in
newspapers so me trying to get what he
has has nothing to do with that
but i understand you have concerns from
a mother protecting your children
shahida goes on to basically tell shaida
that because she wasn't with bilal
shooting in the gym
you weren't with me shooting in the gym
he needs to protect himself and yes i
just went there i don't know how
well you know below or how long you've
known him but i know it isn't 10 years
or 15 years of putting in you know the
work that you see
that he has produced and so
you know the kids have been here
i have been here so i'm coming from that
point of view where he needs to protect
himself and for the children's sake
okay
here's what i think about this whole
prenup situation
and just hear me out alright
the older i get the more these fairytale
ideas i had about love are starting to
shrink
and get smaller and smaller
or i should say more realistic
because i still believe in love and the
beauty of it but i'm learning that if
you want to sustain a relationship
you have to be practical
we as human beings are so complex and
complicated
and i'm learning how important it is to
create a partnership that's tailored
specifically to you and your partner's
needs in the relationship
and with that comes letting go of these
ideas you had about how the relationship
should be
i just wanted us to have a love so sorry
about a prenuptial agreement in between
us
and that doesn't mean settle that's not
what i'm saying what i'm saying is
i don't think below wanting a prenup
means he doesn't really love shaida or
believe in them as a couple
but in my opinion
based off his situation
it's practical he has two young kids and
he's worked hard to set them up to have
a good future
now if he didn't have kids and he was
asking for a prenup
i would be concerned but the reality is
that he does and sometimes relationships
don't work out
especially ones that move pretty fast
plus he's gotten a divorce before so
those rose-colored glasses are off for
him at this point i love shaida very
much
but love isn't blind like
i don't live to the point of view where
i lose my head he knows everything isn't
guaranteed to always work out the way he
wants it to he's been there before
every person who's loved me or who i've
loved back
has left me therapy therapy but back to
shaida and his ex-wife
yeah
well
i think that's a conversation builder
and i definitely need to have
and i think we haven't reached an
agreement when it comes to that
okay
i would love to hear bilal's explanation
to why he didn't set up a meeting for
them are you good
i mean
it is what it is i guess at this point
but
i am just praying for everything just to
go right for the whole situation
i feel completely caught off guard like
where does this hostility come from
shaida thinks shaheed is giving her so
much attitude because she's a little
jealous it took her by surprise to see a
new woman in bilal's home
who is now becoming the woman of the
household
maybe maybe not
i honestly think this is just a very
unique situation they are all in and
shahida is worried about her kids and
their dad
either way
all of this has shied of feeling
overwhelmed i realized that this prenup
is big business
but sweetheart you are lecturing the
wrong person
i am not some little girl of on the
roadside that bilal picked up by talking
on social media i mean i'm a
accomplished woman in trinidad
everything feels different now i think
it's like welcome to america scheida
oh she's given up a lot to be here
and while below says he needs a prenup
for peace of mind we really need to
communicate and come to some sort of
understanding when it comes to this
print up
i'm just glad she's asserting her needs
as well
and saying okay you want me to sign
those papers
i'm gonna need to have kids before a
certain age
because as her sister said
time is ticking
i'm looking forward to seeing what they
end up doing i'm assuming in real time
they're married now
if i didn't somebody would definitely
wipe her up quick so i know rumors are
circulating that they are
hopefully we'll get that confirmed soon
all right next week shaida is looking
pretty in green
but below's trust issues have her down
in the dumps
i brung up having you know the
prenuptial agreement so here is a hard
copy
he has trust issues and i feel like i
have to pay the price for everything
that has happened to him in his past
you're just
looking at me as if i have some secret
agenda
do you ever plan on
divorcing me
and if that is the case who's going to
admit to that
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with e.t because we are covering
it all i will see you next time
[Music]